how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about all things Marvel and of course
everything relating to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe unfortunately it's
been a pretty rough time due to the
coronavirus a lot of movies have been
pushed back from their original release
dates and production for films and TV
shows at Marvel Studios has been halted
as well but in the midst of all this bad
news we have gotten some good news
venom 2 is still on track for its
October 2nd release date and Marvel
Studios and Disney are still planning on
releasing Black Widow in theaters and
just last night Disney Plus has teased
us with some x-men news now there's a
lot that comes with this x-men news and
I'm going to break down every single
thing that we know about it and the more
we find out the more I'll update you one
so be sure to subscribe and
notifications turned on so you don't
miss out on anything
so last night many people noticed that
Disney Plus has added many different
x-men icon images to it now Disney Plus
already has a lot of animated Marvel
shows on it the x-men spider-man
Fantastic Four at the Silver Surfer etc
so at first glance many people didn't
really think too much about this but
since then several hours have passed by
and overnight some sites are reporting
that there may be more to this that
meets the eye
specifically MCU cosmic comm has
reported in an article on the site
stating that they have learned that
there is something related to the x-men
in the works now there are a lot of
things that this could be but there are
some things that we can rule out
considering the fact that these icons
are the 90s versions of the x-men it's
probably not going to be something like
the new mutants that's probably not
going to be released on Disney Plus now
of course there is always the
possibility that there could be a Marvel
Studios x-men show coming to Disney Plus
recently we found out that Disney and
Marvel Studios are working on two disney
plushies that we don't know about yet
and they're keeping it well under wraps
so there is a possibility but it's still
not likely it's most likely further out
and since we are seeing these icons on
Disney Plus now that's most likely not
the case however the great news is for
x-men fans is that we are probably going
to be getting a revival of the original
90s x-men series and this means new
episodes coming to Disney Plus now not
too long ago the creators of the
original 90s x-men series said that they
were going
pitch a revival to Disney and we have to
remember that there is a little bit of a
different structure over at Marvel and
Disney now Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios is also now the CCO the
chief creative officer over Marvel
Studios as well
this means that he now has full creative
control over the TV shows and that
includes what comes out on Disney Plus
he's now in charge of all television
from Marvel and he's a huge 90s x-men
fan so this is the most likely scenario
of what is going to be added to Disney
Plus and I know this is just absolutely
incredible news to many of the people
who grew up watching the nineties x-men
series so now not only will we get to
live in the nostalgia of watching the
90s x-men animated series but we're
going to get new episodes and to get to
fall in love with the x-men all over
again super exciting news everybody let
me know in the comments down below did
you watch the x-men 90's animated show
whether you watched it in the 90's or
watched it later on let me know and let
me know how pumped you are to possibly
get a revival for the show be sure to
like the video and subscribe when
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to Marvel
and of course the MCU and so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or ps4 follow me on Twitter for
live updates and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof